الرياضه السيارات ليست رياضه مجال نسائي
ولو تشوف العالم كله طلع لي بطله عالم
يعني انثى ما في لانه كل اللي استخدمهم
الاعلام استخدمهم بعدين رماهم وكثير لو
تتفرج طلعها الاعلام مقابلات جرائد ورعاه
خذوا حاجاتهم منها البروز
ما تلقاها ما تلقاها
المتسابق سعيد الموري
متسابق رياض السيارات احد
ما ابغى اقول ابطال المملكه احد شباب
المملكه اللي ان شاء الله يمثلها خير
تمثيل متسابق رسميا 2006 يعني
مسكت وانا صغير وتعلمت السيارات وحبيتها
الى اليوم هذا من عام الحين يمكن عشرين
سنه
وانا كلها تخصصي بس فقط سيارات رياضه
سيارات سباقات والتدريب
[موسيقى]
اي احد في جيلي اللي هو جيل 2000 او
المواليد الثمانينات بس الجيل اللي عصرنا
اخر التسعينات والالفين ما كان عندنا شيء
نسويه في السعوديه او في الرياض كان عندنا
نفرق طاقتنا في التفحيط
وكانت هي مبدا انه اثبات اثبات وجود في كل
يبغى يتعلم التفحيط يبغى يثبت مرجلته اول
شيء كل شيء يبقى الله وقدره ولكن لا يمكن
تعتقد او انا اقولها كذا بالعاميه كذاب
اللي يقول انا متحكم في السياره هذا غير
صادق ابرز المفحطين في الفترات اللي فاتت
معروفين ناس معروفه ولكن في
كثير كثير كثير فوق ما تتخيل ناس مالها
القاب ناس بس كذا تبغى تبغى تاخذ سياره
تطلع وتجرب بس وتوزن وبس فانا كنت من الصف
الثاني يعني او حتى الصف الثالث فكانت
الناس اول سبب الشهره ثاني سبب تفريق طاقه
ثالث سبب
هذا في السباقات الان
[موسيقى]
الرياضه بالعكس رياضه السيارات لا ترى
رياضه متعبه بشكل كبير الناس قاعد في
سياره وتسوق ابدا ابدا متعبه متعبه يعني
فيها مجهود مجهود كبير على على الجسم ايضا
في سباقات شاركنا فيها سباقات تحمل 24
ساعه سباق 24 ساعه متواصله وانت قاعد تسوق
وتبدل مع ساقين معاك زملاء في الفريق يدك
تتحرك طول الوقت عينك وراسك اتحرك طول
الوقت اقدامك تتحرك بين فرامل البنزين
وكلاشي طول الوقت طول الوقت انت شغال يعني
يعني حتى شرب المويه في سباقات في اماكن
معينه نقدر نشرب فيها مويه مع ان اللي
موجود بفمك بس من كثر ما انت مشغول بين
فرامل وقير وهذا احيانا ما يمديك تشرب
مويه فهي رياضه متعبه بشكل كبير ترى اليوم
في سباقات الكارتينغ في مشاريع كثير تدفع
50 100 ريال وتسوق كابتن عشر دقائق بس
العبها وبعدين بتجاوب على نفسك على كارت
صغيره سياره يعني اصغر من
من طاوله طعام تسوقها بسرعتها ما توصل 60
تنزل من عشر دقائق وانت منهك معرق وتعبان
فيها فيها جهد كبير مره
[موسيقى]
خطر وصعب طرق جبليه كلها زي ابها والجنوب
بين بيوت فوق الجبل كلنا فانا كنت امشي
يمكن 150 160 في منعطف صغير كذا ورا بيت
بحكم الرالي ينطلقون سياره ورا سياره كل
دقيقتين سياره فكان قدامي المنطلقين وانا
كنت ورا ففي حجاره على الطريق وفي منعطف
ضيق جدا انا جاي يمكن امشي 150 160 بس
بعشق رابع بهدي شوي يعني على 130 الف سعد
دخلت اللفه الا فيه حجر مرمي في الطريق
فضربتها
وكذا في وادي صغير تحت وطحت فيه
السياره ما جاها شيء يعني كثير ولكن من
قوه الضربه الوقوف من سرعه 130 وقفت فجاه
هذه هذه اللي ضرتني لو متقلب كان ما حسيت
بشيء
صار عندي شرخ في الحوض وانزلاق والملاح
انكسر ظهره بس الحمد لله سهلات يعني
[موسيقى]
لا ابدا الحمد لله بالعكس الخطوره ما هي
بعاليه زي ما تعطي الناس تعتقد احنا اليوم
رياضه السيارات كل مالها تضاف اليه عوامل
سلامه اكثر اكثر اليوم احنا في اشياء
نجربها بعد خمس سنين تلقاها عندك في اشياء
احنا جربناه من ثلاث اربع سنين سواء في
الاطارات جربناها او في قطع في السياره
اليوم هي موجوده في سيارتك عوامل امان
اوامر السلامه قطع تتحمل مسافات طويله فهي
مختبر مختبر متنقل بالعكس انت تقول لي
اركض اركب خيل واركض على شيء ولا سياره
بقول لك مركب في السياره انا الخيل ممكن
اطيح وينكسر ظهري ولا يصير لي شيء بس في
السياره انا محاط بعوامل السلامه ان شاء
الله انه اقل خطوره من الخير
هي متاكد
[موسيقى]
انك كنت ورا جيب ومسرعين فريغا ما اشوف
وكان المطر ذيك الايام في وادي الدواسر
كانت المرحله
فانا وراه وراء طايرين طايرين انا ما ابغى
اروح عني لانه ما يقدر يروح يمين ولا يسار
الباب لازم امشي معاه في نفس المسار لانه
في قشوع لو طلعت على المسار يمكن اقلب
بقيت خلاص
ركز قاعد اطالع في اذكر والله اني طالع في
النسافات حقت الجيب بس منزل عيني اشوف
لونها ازرق والله اني اذكرها للحين قاعد
اقول ايوه
وصل عند البركه ولف يمين انا ما دام ثاني
فطبيت
والحمدة قعد دعس طلعت مع الجهه الثانيه
ولكني شربت يمكن لترين مويه من البركه
كلها طحالب وما ادري ايش دخل بطني وقتها
في اذكر انه في شيء اخضر كان يسبح ودخل
فمي بس ما ادري رحت للمركز الطبي وشرحت
لهم اعطوني والله محلول ومدري ايش قالوا
ان شاء الله تزين امورك واذا ارتفعت
حرارتك تعال واذا ما ارتفعت ان شاء الله
عايبي فالحمد لله ما ارتفعت الحراره
طب احنا وقت السباق لازم نلبس اول شيء
اندرويد او ملابس داخليه من تحت لفوق تبدا
تكرمه من الشراب هذه ما هي ضد الحريق
ولكنها تعطيك وقت انها ما تحترق ولا تلزق
في جسمك فهي واقيه بعدين نلبس فوقها
البدله اللي هي ايضا مقاومه للحريق فتره
اطول بعدين فوقها او الجاسوس ايضا هذه
التكرمون الجزمه ايضا مقاومه للحريق الى
حد معين بعدين نلبس نغطي الوجه نسميه او
القناع هذا ايضا بعدين الخوذه
والخوذه في شيء سمى الهاس ديفايس اللي هو
جاي ينربط في الصدر او على الكتف تربط في
الخوذه عشان لا سمح الله صار حادث قوي
خلني اقولها بالعميه ما تنخنع رقبتك او ما
تفلتي يمسك الرقبه فهذا هو بعد كذا نربط
الاحزمه ونتوكل على الله اي والله يا ساتر
حر مو طبيعي ترى يعني توصل الحراره في
الراليات في بعض السباقات توصل حراره جوا
السياره الى خمسين ستين
حر مو طبيعي وتخيل انك تسوق ساعتين
متواصله بعدين تبدل بعدين اللي بعدك بعدين
ترجع تسوق ساعتين يصير هناك يعني انا اذكر
مرتين في سباقات 24 ساعه هذه ينكسر سني من
كثر ما انا مركز واضغط على فمي انكسر سني
مشاركه عمل وتسعه وعشره انقطع عليه
البنزين وانا في نص المرحله وكان في مخيم
بعيد يمكن يبعد عني كيلو وسط البر بعيد
فانا قعدت استنى خلال نص ساعه كذا الا
جاني شايب شايب كبير في السن وقف عندي
سلامات يا ولدي قلت الله يسلمك قطعنا
بنزين قال لي
يا رجال انت اللي مع السباق قلتي قال
الرجاجيل روحوا يقول قلت حنا بين كل سياره
وسياره دقيقتين فهو لما شاف سيارات قالولي
راحت يعتقد انه اني خلاص انا ورا
قال يعني بتلحقهم قلت باقي سيارات ورائي
بتجي بعد قال اجل بنزين تبي قلت نتغدى
عندي انت يا عم الله يطول في عمرك قال
والله ما تدق البنزين لين اتغدى عندي
حب راسه الله يغنيك والله لارجع لك بعد
الرالي قال ابتن ما في بنزين انا وياه انا
وياه انا وياه لين قال لا تذوق اي شيء من
عندي شوف الكرم كيف الله يطول في عمره حلف
منه ما قال خلاص ابشر راح جاب لي بنزين
وجاب مع تمر وفاكهه قال هذا البنزين تاكل
خذ البنزين والله اكلت تمر وذا وقال هاك
البنزين
السيارات مكلفه جدا مكلفه مكلفه مكلفه فوق
ما تتخيل يعني ولكن هو لازم معايير معينه
انه ممكن الناس تدفع لك خبرتك
خبرتك في القياده
اثنين عدد حوادثك قله حوادثك ثلاثه نتائجك
اربعه مصداقيتك ففي اشياء كثيره تحدد انك
ممكن يندفع لك او ممكن ما يندفع لك انك
تسوق اليوم في سباقات
بس سيارات غاليه او ثريه او او
ما تنتج ابطال نهائيا في نهايه المطاف ولا
واحد من هذا من خبرتي في المجال ما
يستمرون اغلب اللي يدخل بالشكل هذا يدخل
بس ياخذ الهاله الاعلاميه حوله وخلاص ما
يستمر فقط الطموح واللي حاب يستثمر في
نفسه في رياضه السيارات
يقولون للناس انت ليش تسوق التريلا محقتك
كلهم يا اخي انا مبسوط باستطاعتي اليوم
اجيب سائق يسوقها واركب سيارتي واقول انا
بطل المملكه واشخص بس فعليا ما انبسط
والله كذا امسك الخط السوق التريلا واروح
روقان ما بعد الروقان والله اني اغني على
نفسي يطلع صوت صدى في التريلا فاطرف نفسك
بنفسك يطلع صوت صدى تريله كبيره فتحس نفسك
ساره اكادمي والله ما احس نفسي الا وصلت
ولا اوقف محطه اعبي ديزل باكل لك عدس الله
احلى والله اللي ما جرب العدس في محطه في
الخط هذا ما جرب يكون افغاني يسوي بعدين
يجيك كاتب
ها واو وبعدين حط الطاء بدال النقطتين
ولام وقف لا تسال وقف هذي المشكله ستارت
حقت مطاعم الخط